- Hi everyone, I'm Oscar Isaac.
- And I'm Ethan Hawke.
OSCAR ISAAC
And we are about to watch the trailer
of our new series Moon Knight,
on Disney+. You ready?
ETHAN HAWKE
Yeah. Hit the spacebar.
OSCAR ISAAC
Let's do this.
[Clock ticking]
OSCAR ISAAC
I can really do a Rubik's cube,
by the way.
ETHAN HAWKE
You're kind of like a genius.
OSCAR ISAAC
I am.
ETHAN HAWKE
Ok. This is creepy so far.
OSCAR ISAAC
Uh-huh.
ETHAN HAWKE
I'm liking it.
OSCAR ISAAC
My waking life...
Please, sir, can I have some more?
ETHAN HAWKE
Are you laughing or crying?
OSCAR ISAAC
Maybe... We don't know.
ETHAN HAWKE
Why do you have restraints in your bed?
That's not cool.
♫ Day and night ♫
OSCAR ISAAC
A little Kid Cudi. Come on!
♫ In my mind ♫
STEVEN
I'm losing it.
ETHAN HAWKE
That's my favorite shot right there.
OSCAR ISAAC
That's a good one.
DONNA
You're bloody useless.
- She makes me laugh.
- Lucy, she's like the best.
OSCAR ISAAC
So funny.
ETHAN HAWKE
With a V.
OSCAR ISAAC
Stevie with a V.
Oh, oh!
What was that?
ETHAN HAWKE
All right, that's creepy.
You gotta... you gotta get more rest.
[Screams]
[Elevator dings]
ELDERLY WOMAN
Thank you.
STEVEN
Lost a contact lens.
ELDERLY WOMAN
Hope you find it.
STEVEN
Thanks.
OSCAR ISAAC
This March!
My birthday's in March,
it's a good sign.
Oh!
The reflection!
What was that about?
ETHAN HAWKE
Oh! Pyramid.
Crocodile.
OSCAR ISAAC
Old flip phone.
LAYLA
You're alive! What's wrong with you, Marc?
STEVEN
Why did you call me Marc?
♫ Day and night ♫
OSCAR ISAAC
Uh-oh...
ETHAN HAWKE
I look a little bit like Brando
in Island of Dr. Moreau.
[Laughing]
OSCAR ISAAC
It's the best Brando.
STEVIE
Shut! Up!
ARTHUR HARROW
There's chaos in you.
OSCAR ISAAC
That was a lot of self-inflicted pain.
- Ah!
- Whoa!
- Pyramids, Egypt.
- Uh-oh.
ARTHUR HARROW
Embrace the chaos.
OSCAR ISAAC
That's right. Oh, I see white. Oh!
ETHAN HAWKE
Oh!
OSCAR ISAAC
And there he is.
In all his glory.
ETHAN HAWKE
Who is he, who is he?
BOTH
Ahhh! [Laughing]
OSCAR ISAAC
Yes!
♫ At, at, at night ♫